so nice to finally meet you in
spider-man here Nick Fury put some
clothes on just go for a ride is he
gonna be okay like that might want to
turn him over so he doesn't swallow his
tongue
unique theory just hijacked our summer
vacation
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit and I really respect him
sup dickwad so nice to finally meet you
spider-man why don't I hook you up with
even more brand new suits
so you can take down Mysterio and expose
him as the fraud that he is so we got a
whole bunch of new stuff to break down
apparently there's another new suit in
spider-man far from home that we just
found out about so we'll explain what's
going on there was also some new funny
Mysterio Easter eggs in real life on
social in the last week because of the
holiday that I'll break down so we'll do
a new round of that Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
spider-man suit on the video the big
news is is that it looks like they have
a version of the spider UK suit in the
movie now that doesn't mean that they're
doing Spider UK it just means that
there's a variant of the stark tech suit
just based on the way it looks
that would bring spider-man's grand
total in the MCU up to five different
suits including the original stark tech
suit the iron spider suit the new black
stealth suit that looks like the
spider-man 2 arc costume and then
obviously the new black red Steve Ditko
variant of the stark tech suit 5 being
this new spider UK version of the suit
the new black and red one that we see in
the trailer in London when he's flying
in to go against one of those elementals
I'm just gonna call that the Steve Ditko
stark tech suit because it looks like
someone just took the base design of the
stark tech suit and modified it the
spider-man noir stealth suit seems like
a completely new difference to built
from the ground up like it's not based
on the stark tech suit although it
probably some similar technology the
reason why we know about this new spider
UK suit is obviously because of the toy
lines so I'll explain how I think this
might wind up in the movie because the
toy stuff is a little bit different
based on our experience with infinity
war recently there's just such a big
movie obviously everybody gets a new
version of a costume but some of those
wind up on the cutting room floor or
wind up in deleted scenes so this spider
UK suit seems even more like the
original stark tech suit just painted
with white highlights and blue over the
black highlights like all the black
stripes from the original suit are white
and look at the belt line here the black
belt is now colored blue more obviously
to resemble the UK flag a la spiderman
UK if you've been playing spider-man ps4
recently the Spyder UK suit from the
comics is in that it looks a little bit
different than this start tech version
of the Spyder UK suit but if you ever
wondered why they do stuff like this
there's a practical reason why they keep
things so similar to previous versions
of the costume and a lot of it is in the
name of merchandising it's a lot easier
for them to take all the leftovers stark
tech spider-man toys from the first
movie a long time ago like there's
probably piles and piles and warehouses
of
unsold spider-man toys and just recolor
them a little bit differently repackage
them for the new movie and save
themselves a bunch of money so they
don't have to make a bunch of new toys
they just repaint a lot of the old toys
they've done that for every single movie
that you've ever gone to see they do it
for different toy wins - like
transformers anything it's just a really
easy way for movie studios to capitalize
on the characters without spending a
bunch of extra money that is why Ironman
gets a new suit in every single movie
and sometimes multiple different suits
within a movie so they can sell those
extra toys I mean usually it winds up
being really cool in whatever scene
they're used in but a lot of times like
Iron Man 3 is like the uber version of
that where you have many many different
armors they sold toys for all those even
though those armors were only in the
movie for a very brief period before he
blew them all up at the end so there's a
big question about how much this version
of spider UK makes it into spider-man
far from home or if it just winds up
being a background Easter egg and a
visual reference worth it was just a
really early idea that winds up in a
deleted scene or on the cutting room
floor because a lot of times you don't
find out about that till months after
the film comes out I did a whole bunch
of that for Avengers infinity war they
revealed all these deleted scenes and
concepts months after the film came out
there was an original comic book version
of the iron spider suit that they
thought about putting in the movie for a
little while
there was a black version of the costume
there were all these other variants we
already know about a couple confirmed
new suits in the film they're probably
hundreds and hundreds of different ideas
that they poured over before they landed
on these two designs but here's on a
basic level the reason why they would
want to do something like this is
because they're gonna spend a lot of the
film in London if it's gonna be an
international jet-setting man of mystery
James Bond spider-man of course you want
to feature more international comic book
Easter eggs so that doesn't mean that
they're actually gonna do spider-man UK
Benjamin Braddock in the film but there
were rumors early on that they were
going to include British spider-man
comic
book characters in the film in some way
Jessica drew was the biggest rumor that
I saw early on and she still hasn't been
confirmed but the rumor wasn't that she
was going to be Spider Woman during the
movie the rumor was is that it would
just be Jessica drew a law enforcement
agent that was just doing regular stuff
so we haven't quite got to live-action
spider-verse yet but that does feel like
the logical direction for them to go
with the franchise after they get done
with whatever ten-year plan they have
for Tom Holland like eventually he will
want to transition to a more background
role like the phase 1 Avengers but that
is so far down the road that it is way
too early to speculate on what they
might do with live-action spider-verse
but they've already introduced Miles
Morales in spider-man homecoming that
was the scene here where Donald Glover
who's playing a version of the Prowler
mentions his nephew Aaron Davis age 33
the other night you told that dude if
you're gonna shoot somebody shoot me
it's pretty ballsy
I don't want those weapons in his
neighborhood I got a nephew who live
here as of right now in the MCU miles is
the first additional spider person that
they've even hinted at he's so young and
present-day that I would be amazed if
they even got close to live action Miles
Morales before the end of whatever Tom
Horne's third spider-man movie winds up
being if you're not familiar with
spider-man UK or you haven't been
playing spider-man ps4 Billy Braddock's
spider-man UK is an alternate universe
version of Captain Britain mixed with
spider-man's backstory sort of like
Captain Britain with the powers and
abilities of spider-man from a different
universe he appeared for the first time
during the spider-verse comic book event
in 2014 so he's a relatively new
character so I don't think this is gonna
debut someone like him before they do
just get drew or Miles Morales or any of
the other versions of spider-man I know
people have been asking about Clone Saga
what about Ben Riley that's all open to
speculation they haven't said anything
about that yet just remember that
whatever they do Kevin Feige is like mr.
Peter Parker spider-man so I think that
there's always going to be a version of
Peter Parker spider-man in the MCU no
matter what they do with other
spider-verse characters spider-man is
the biggest Marvel character he
is the jewel in the crown such an
amazing icon he is a very different type
of hero because he is quite simply the
greatest superhero of all time so in
real life recently in related Mysterio
news you may have seen Jake Gyllenhaal
trolling spider-man on Instagram for
Valentine's Day now he was just making
fun of him but the real-life meta Easter
egg here is that Mysterio in the movie
is obsessed with spider-man Peter Parker
and the Avengers this is the clip of
them from back at comic-con talking
about how the core of the movie is his
relationship Mysterio's relationship
with Peter Parker spider-man there are
these threats to the worlds the
elementals elemental creatures in there
and mysterious woman you know who who
knows about them and wants to make sure
that the world is safe from them and and
Nick Fury asked him to come on and help
because he's the only one who really
sort of understands them in a way and
and then you know he teams up with
friendly neighborhood spider-man and
unfortunately has to make him become
more than just a friendly neighborhood
spider-man and for me I know there are a
lot of movies but this character
Mysterio when they showed it to me was
so original and the idea and and who he
is and why he's there is so original and
so special that for me I was like man
maybe they did it again you know I
didn't think they could and they do and
they do it every time cool cool it's
really cool I mean the coolest thing
about the suit is that there are some
major secrets in it yeah pretty cool the
important thing to remember about
everything that they're saying is that
they're not lying to you they're just
omitting some of the rug pulling you
know big twist from the movie so the
funny thing about all this press that
they've been doing to hype up hero
Mysterio like Mysterio's the hero this
movie is just to build you up so that it
seems like a bigger twist when they pull
the rug out from under you in the movie
and it turns out Mysterio's probably
been behind all these elementals the
whole time there's a couple videos that
I've done about the sinister six Easter
eggs and potential characters that are
masquerading as these elementals like
there's a Sandman Easter Egg when you
see this giant sand elemental that Nick
Fury Maria Hillier fighting I'll link
that video at the end of this but since
we've been talking about new versions of
spider-man's suit
what other future versions besides
obviously the symbiote in the black suit
do you want to see
spider-man in before they're done with
this new Tom Holland trilogy the success
of venom really does call into question
what they're gonna do with the venom
verse and how much they're gonna bump up
against the MCU because I still think
right now Kevin Feige wants to keep that
stuff separate but if we get any new
details or any new Easter eggs I will
totally make a video about it click here
to rewatch bye spider-man far from home
trailer Easter eggs and click here for
brand new Avengers endgame thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]